as temperatures saw the impacts of the
heat wave became clear
and when it came to travel air and rail
disruption was widespread
luton airport grounded flights after the
runway buckled in smoldering
temperatures
here at licky hills in worcestershire
wildfire engulfed nearly half a square
kilometer it took four fire crews to
stop the blaze spreading
wales has already reported its highest
ever temperature after it hit
37.1 degrees in flintshire and it's
expected that records will be broken
again today across the uk
a 16 year old boy died after getting
into difficulty in berkshire's bray lake
emergency services are facing increase
in callouts london ambulance service has
already seen a 30
rise in calls since last week they're
braced for even more
like care homes across the country here
in west london they're taking extra
precautions to keep residents safe
[Laughter]
hopefully tomorrow we'll be
no we won't be paddling down the road
it's too hot for me
i have to be careful
because my skin is very tender they are
put in a place area in the care home
that is cool making sure that the
windows are closed curtains are closed
and we also put them
like a basin of water
and some wipes that to just stop them
like that on the exposed areas of their
body
these weather patterns are set to become
more common as climate change pushes up
average temperatures extreme heat is
likely to be part of our future aisha
zahid sky news